Ora, se ottengo le ragazze, lo sono
marino e solido da youtube italiano e
questo è il mio primo video in spagnolo
[Musica]
questo è il primo episodio del mio nuovo
formato video chiamato a
youtuber in cucina è questo che sto andando
preparare è uno dei miei piatti preferiti
È qualcosa di molto molto buono che cucino tutto
la domenica per i miei amici lo sono
parlando di tortillas fatte in casa
Gli americani meglio conosciuti con il nome
frittelle oltre alle frittelle dolci
i classici oggi li propongo anche io
nelle tortillas fatte in casa americane ma
salati gli ingredienti di cui abbiamo bisogno
sono 125 ml di latte con 100 grammi di
farina o uova 30 grammi di burro
un cucchiaino di sale e lievito salato
umorismo shake elettrico e cominciamo
Per prima cosa separiamo il tuorlo dal
chiaro
quindi montiamo l'albume con un mixer
mettiamo il burro a diretto in a
pentola attenzione a non bruciarla
aggiungere il burro al tuorlo
lancio
il latte
la farina
il cucchiaino di sale
e lievito
[Musica]
impastare il tutto fino ad ottenere un impasto
liscia e omogenea a cui andremo
aggiungi il bianco
[Musica]
ora mettiamo la padella a scaldare e
aggiungere con cura una piccola quantità
di pasta con un mestolo
quando vediamo in superficie
bolle capovolgiamo il pancake
[Musica]
e fate dorare da entrambi i lati
quindi preparati a riempire
puoi mettere nel ripieno quello che vuoi
piace ma consiglio il mio ripieno
preferito che è salmone affumicato più formaggio
cremoso all'erba cipollina poi spalmiamo il
frittella con crema di formaggio e andiamo
aggiungere due fette di salmone affumicato
e il gioco è fatto, le frittelle salate alla marina
sono pronti e ora continuiamo con il
ricetta classica delle frittelle
american sweets gli ingredienti che
ci servono due uova da 80 grammi
zucchero 200 grammi di farina 200
millilitri di latte 2 cucchiaini di
lievito di mora e lampone e
sciroppo d'acero
Iniziamo versando lo zucchero in una ciotola
aggiungere le uova
e mescolare fino a che liscio
ed omogeneo
ora incorporiamo ina e due
cucchiaini di lievito alla vaniglia
mescolate bene e aggiungete poco alla volta
latte
l'impasto è già fatto
con un mestolo mettiamo in padella
molto caldo una piccola quantità
e aspetta fino al
bolle
poi lo capovolgiamo finché non lo è
marrone su entrambi i lati
[Musica]
Di solito li metto uno sopra l'altro
a formare una piccola torre
poi ha dedicato un bene
quantità di sciroppo d'acero e cospargere
con zucchero di classe
possiamo decorare il piatto con la frutta
foresta
se vuoi preparare una porzione singola
due frittelle sono sufficienti i frutti di
foresta la panna montata e il mio
fantastiche frittelle dolci così buone
che siamo giunti alla fine di questo
video Spero vi sia piaciuto spero
che puoi goderti questi pancake
insieme ai tuoi amici se non l'hai fatto
fatto vi chiedo di iscrivervi al mio canale
e metti mi piace e seguimi in tutto il
altri i miei social network instagram
facebook un grande bacio a tutti cosa
lo fai per aver seguito questo il primo
video che faccio in spagnolo e lo spero
non essere l'ultimo
e
[Musica]